ja millionen nerze werden gerade in
käfigen gehalten in dänemark das auch
schon länger zur pelz sucht alleine das
ist schon tierquälerei doch jetzt werden
sie systematisch getötet denn bei den
tieren ist eine neue variante des corona
virus aufgetaucht und die könnte auch
auf den menschen übertragen werden
fast zwei millionen tiere wurden
deswegen jetzt schon vergast brutale
tötungen in dänemark neue schockierende
aufnahmen zeigen das unerträgliche leid
der korona nerze in dänemark wurde
vergangene woche von der regierung
entschieden dass nach dem auftreten von
merz corona varianten die nerze sterben
müssen
denn er zu zählen wie frettchen zu den
tieren die für das corona virus
empfänglich sind und es dann ab genossen
weitergeben können danach ging das
brutale töten los bereits 1,9 millionen
der etwa 15 millionen nerze in
zuchtanlagen wurden bereits vergast doch
dass das mit viel leid verbunden ist
beweisen diese neuen aufnahmen die am
sonntag in einer pelzfarm in oering
aufgenommen wurden
einige tiere sind nicht ganz tot wenn
sie aus der vergasung kiste
herausgenommen und in den container
geworfen werden hier ist die tötung
falsch verlaufen denn auch die menschen
die die arbeit verrichten stoßen an ihre
grenzen
die nerze sollen innerhalb von zehn
tagen sterben diese zeit frisst ist
wichtig für die züchter davon ihr die
staatliche entschädigungssumme abhängig
ist außerdem stellen die
futtermittelfabriken teilweise ihre
produktion ein
es wird bald kein märz futter mehr geben
das veterinäramt will jetzt dafür sorgen
dass derartige fehler nicht mehr
vorkommen und tv mann ist für uns auf
einer pelzfarm in dänemark wir haben
gerade die schrecklichen aufnahmen
gesehen ist das töten der millionen märz
überhaupt verhältnismäßig auch
angesichts der horrorbilder die wir
gerade gesehen haben nun die dänische
regierung möchte mit aller macht
verhindern dass dieses mutierte corona
virus aus dänische land südlich von
nordjütland wo wir uns jetzt gerade
befinden befinden übergreift war da man
die sorge hat dass diese mutierte
version des gruner virus
nicht mehr von den impfstoffen jetzt
gerade entwickelt wurden angegriffen
werden können
ich stehe jetzt hier mit rihannas kehrt
sie ist jetzt ihr züchterin und sie hat
jetzt gerade quasi 13.000 tiere töten
müssen china
sie uns doch mal bitte was befindet sich
in dem container hinter ihnen indem ich
da liegt das lebenswerk mein
schwiegervater angefangen hat 35 jahre
her
wir haben das letzte von hier sind
ungefähr 6.000 körper liegen
das ist kein spaß überhaupt nicht
und das ist passion das herzblut das
zuchtmaterial das ist der nadel
wiederkommen es gab ja schreckliche
bilder die unsere zuschauer gerade
gesehen haben von tötungen die irgendwie
nicht richtig von statten gehen was
können sie dazu sagen wie konnte es dazu
kommen
es kommt dazu wenden wenn leute die
keine chance haben dass die keine
ausbildung dass wir haben diesen job
machen müssen sofort bloß weil weil
unsere regierung es
ford rücken wollen und es schnell machen
wollen
und anfangs an wurden wurden züchtern
abgeschoben und sagen dass sie sondern
nicht teilnehmen
und das geht nicht gut wir haben da ein
unbedingte verantwort das ordentlich so
machen wir haben zertifizierung und
jeder züchter in dänemark kunde katzen
werden für egal merzen
wenn wir das nicht ort nicht schon dann
stehen also im gefängnis und das ist
fair und deswegen muss das auch nicht
gemacht werden und das war unanständig
es gibt jetzt ja auch viel kritik von
tierschützern auf grund dieser
käfighaltung fast können sie dazu sagen
der käfig ist eigentlich der vom tier da
nicht für uns ein märz war jetzt kann
ich war sagen weil es gibt fast keine
mehr in dänemark und bei mir besonders
nicht
der war sehr territorial und und sie
möchten nicht mit anderen rumlaufen und
und der kiewel ist ausgewickelt um
das für das tier sich wohl zu fühlen und
dass das tier war für dieser welt
gewohnt und war kam sie raus war das
störend und und sie wurden nervös und
ich wurden miteinander kämpfen
das tier war ihr territorium nicht mein
also wenn ich ein käfig öffnete war das
als besucher und was haben sie da
hinterhand was haben sie dort gemacht
dass das ist von keiner meiner meine
geschäft ich habe neben an unserer
produktion an produktion von von
schmuckstück und und sandte projekt
produkten für für leute mit angst mit
adt mit autismus ausgewickelt
und naja wie das weiter kommt weiß ich
jetzt nicht weil mein plan war ich
wollte es nur von von feldprogramm
unserer eigenen farm machen weil da
könnte ich unbedingt verantwortlich
stehen
wie die produkten hier kamen und das ist
ordentlich gemacht war weil für mich war
ordnung muss sein einfach dem weg und
das werde es immer noch werden aber
nicht mehr ärzten leide nicht
ja sie nah wie du gehört hast die chinas
gehört hat jetzt als sie ihrem ihr
lebenswerk verloren
tierschützer könnte das freuen da jetzt
ja diese tiere hier wohl nicht mehr
gezüchtet werden allerdings haben hier
jetzt auch verena mir erzählte ungefähr
50.000 menschen ihren job verloren
hey vielleicht kannst uns noch eine
kurze nachfrage beantworten was passiert
dann jetzt mit den pelzen der toten
tiere ja nie was passiert denn jetzt mit
diesen toten tieren können die pelze
noch benutzt werden oder was passiert
leider nicht dass das ist im eimer
weil wir in eine zone war wegen wir
hatten eine kollege der leider wir
diesen virus
fallen musste dürfen wir wägen eine
eu-direktive nicht diesen tieren
benutzten also die gehen heute abend
nachverbrennung dass das ist es gibt
hierfür millionen euro als insgesamt
felsen die maschine oder sonstwo
geschickt werden können
jetzt werde die möglichkeit der china
vielleicht dass das produktion
übernehmen nicht die tiere aber der
produktion und dass wir nicht mit selber
politik als wir haben und das ist so das
können wir jetzt nicht ändern
das einzige was wir können sagen können
ist dass wir sind stolz dass wir haben
das gut gemacht und das wir hatten das
der beste direktive tierpflege europas
ihr habt uns selbst aus gewickelt aber
das ist jetzt geschichte
ja also li na sagt sagte mir auch vorher
schon dass die dänische pelztier
produktion wohl sie sagte sie waren die
weltmeister und jetzt wird
wahrscheinlich dieses geschäft nach
china gehen
dankeschön biermann live aus dänemark
sind die tiere wirklich umsonst
gestorben
danke dir mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren